et chef de la direction financière de
huawei one jo subi un important revers
aujourd'hui devant les tribunaux la cour
suprême de la colombie-britannique a
jugé que le crime qui lui est reproché
par les états unis pourraient aussi
constituer un crime au canada ça veut
donc dire que la procédure d'extradition
vers les états unis va se poursuivre
même où joe est accusé de fraude dans le
caire dans l'objectif de contourner les
sanctions américaines contre l'iran
la fraude bancaire est un crime dans les
deux pays et le canada n'impose pas de
sanctions contre l'iran
alex payet est professeur adjoint à
l'université york spécialiste des
politiques domestiques de la chine pour
soir monsieur payet
bonjour du bignon quel est l'impact
selon votre analyse de cette décision
sur les relations commerciales entre le
canada et la chine d'écouter un coût
moyen terme
on envisage kir peu d'impact parce qu'en
fait entendre de mesures de représailles
c'est à dire donc peut-être de revenir
sur certaines des barrières qui avait
été mis à 20 sur exemple le port le
boeuf et tout ça qui ont été remis fin
2019 ou encore le canola qui avait été
remis fin mars
donc tout ça va sûrement revenir
éventuellement donc on veut créer des
problèmes pour le canada au niveau des
exportations vers la chine mais ça sera
pas dans l'immédiat tandis que la chine
est en ce moment dans une période un peu
trouble donc ça va prendre plusieurs
semaines voire plusieurs mois avant de
voir les effets dirons-nous concret de
cette décision conduit aujourd'hui et
donc ça va prendre un certain temps mais
est ce que ça pourrait quand même mené à
d'éventuelles nouvelles sanctions de la
chine ce que la chine pourrait donc
répondre quand même sur le plan
économique mais comme je disais il ya
des secteurs qui vont être affectés
beaucoup plus que dans tout ce qui à
gros alimenta donc si on voit bientôt en
question par soya canola tout ça va être
problématique et indécis
où sont engloutis beijing joue ses
cartes correctement si on va sûrement se
réapproprient ces lignes
d'approvisionnement déportation vers les
états unis tout en fait
l'étiquette de remplir les quotas de la
première phase du traité qui est le
signe que les états unis n'ont pas
réussi dans un premier temps et dans un
deuxième temps on pourrait voir aussi
une séquence de désinvestissement
surtout dans les secteurs miniers de
matières premières ou d'acquisition de
compagnies canadiennes par les
compagnies chinoises et ça pourrait
aller d'un petit peu plus dans le long
terme
parfait est ce que c'est est ce que
cette affaire a un impact sur la
décision du canada d'accepter ou de ne
pas accepter que huawei participe au
développement de sa technologie et de la
technologie 5g au pays probablement oui
mais ce qui est difficile
si on va évaluer pour l'instant c'est
que trois oui quand même le producteur
important de la technologie 5 gic et
qu'une capacité à déployer qui est
important donc est-ce que est bon et
proche du gouvernement donc grandes
problématiques liées à la fiabilité de
la technologie va aussi la
confidentialité ils vont toucher les
toujours de choses qui sont pas réglés
comme ça donc est-ce que c'est
nécessairement seulement cette décision
qui pèse dans toute l'histoire
probablement pas le programme beaucoup
plus que simplement cette décision de
l'ue qui est arrivé aujourd'hui donc en
après midi hier souvent plus que ça a dû
jouer un petit peu meilleure plus que ça
mais est-ce que huawei pour dire ben
écoutez le nous on demande la libération
de marwan jo vous allez pas de l'avant
avec ça on se retire du canada est ce
que ça fait possible oui c'est possible
mais étant donné qu'ils commencent avant
des levées de boucliers un petit peu
partout
le mouroir oui comment c'est un peu
synonyme de problématiques
d'associations gouvernementale avec le
chinois et tout ça donc
est ce que c'est une bonne idée pour
rory de se retirer d'un marché pour
cette raison pas nécessairement
oui on va encore beaucoup de téléphone
je pense qu'on était encore le numéro
deux dans le top 5 l'année dernière
c'est quand même pas rien considérant
les circonstances
mais est-ce qu'on va ensuite en plus se
retirer d'un énorme projet
d'infrastructure comme sa course comme
on pour les livres comptables de roy oui
ce serait pas vraiment une bonne
décision et donc est ce que le canada à
quelques leviers de négociations avec la
chaîne of moment si on parle de la
sphère fois oui techniquement parlant
plus ou moins parce que bon il faut
ition si on voi s'ils ont vu la
temporalité de la chose
la valeur de mon de membres fait dans le
temps diminue au fur et à mesure que les
choses avancent et il le fait qu'elle ne
revient pas devient peu un nouveau
normal
nous avons le plus grand chose à tirer
de vouloir essayer de négocier sur ce
point d'aller chercher des leviers avec
la chine sur sa donc la valeur était
beaucoup plus si l'an dernier ou au
début où tout est pas qu'on l'arrêté le
y avait une valeur réelle on aurait pu
négocier quelque chose mais aujourd'hui
plus ou moins quelques mots parce que
vous suivez fait de très très près sur
un camp sur la loi sur la sécurité
nationale a encore il ya des
manifestations bien sûr en ce moment
compte tenu du comportement de pékin
face à l'arrogance
qu'est-ce que vous surveillez de près là
dessus en fait ce qu'on attend de voir
si cuba revenir rapidement c'est que
vont il ya les deux assemblées qui sont
en cours depuis le 21 et donc c'est la
grande assemblée dit on nous dit
ghislaine yves et à la journée numéro un
donc le mercredi l'assemblée nationale a
déposé un brouillon d'un projet de loi
sur la sécurité nationale pour l'île de
hong kong
et ça ce que ça veut dire en fait c'est
que beijing outrepasserait
bon parlement du point de vue que vous
voulez le mettre bon sens strict et doit
outre passer les lois locales de hong
kong et la garantie du un pays du
système dont dire que hong kong
si on veut évoluer une façon différente
on allait au delà des garanties curé de
la hong kong et imposer une loi qui en
fait cru différée jusqu'à un certain
point le lèse majesté ton qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire que hong kong
deviendrait une partie qui n'est plus
est dépendante de la chine et donc on
pourrait lui révoqué chance là dessus si
on veut de centres financiers nous son
statut spécial économique qu'elle avait
un peu partout dans le monde mais
surtout avec les états unis
donc si on la reverra ont non seulement
le brouillon mais ça regarde pas très
bien pour l'instant
donc si on va vers ça le problème ça va
bien pourquoi est ce que on y est encore
investir en grand très bien on utilise
toute façon ce dossier de près a
l'expérience merci merci